d'après les touristes la seconde
acheteurs/vendeurs d'accord également
quand même pour arriver jusqu'au salon
des acheteurs étrangers ne connaissent
pas les affres des embouteillages de
l'autoroute du nord de cambrai ont prévu
des escortes passe partout alors
confortablement installés dans ces
chalets de bord de piste les
propriétaires de ces puissante limousine
discute à faire plus que vous traitez
véritablement rap on profite du salon
pour annoncer entre pourquoi les
résultats
vous avez la négociation d'une grande
affaire militaire demande entre deux et
trois heures alors traiter des affaires
négocier non en conclure qu'ils sont en
négociation depuis longtemps oui bien
sûr là vous avez réussi quand même une
belle affaire avec l'arabie saoudite
mais l'arabie saoudite sera le sixième
clients dans le monde
le missile mistral qui est le système le
plus évolué dans sa catégorie dans le
monde aux angles
la signature annoncée par matra par
exemple avec l'arabie saint paul sur un
marché exceptionnel
la livraison d'un système de missiles
sol air va conjugue mistral un milliard
de francs pour la première tranche
concernant un millier de missiles
le chiffre exact reste confidentiel
le mistral est un engin de 20 kg qui
peut être servie par deux hommes grâce à
un équipement 10 ultra léger sa porte et
permet de contrôler l'espace aérien dans
un rayon de 5 km cet engin déjà vendu à
2000 exemplaires détrône maintenant le
célèbre bissy américain stinger sur les
stands de la concurrence les catalogues
d'armes font appel aux dessins animés
il s'agit de valoriser au maximum les
performances
comment un bon militaire pourrait il
résister à la tentation d'acheter un
missile guidé par une caméra vidéo qui
renvoie son image aux pilotes resté au
sol
cela grâce à un minuscule fils en fibre
optique qui se déroule derrière le
missile un marché qui fait mouche
pourtant ces contrats fabuleux qui se
chiffre en milliards de francs et qui
donne du travail à des dizaines de
milliers de personnes ne doivent pas
faire oublier que les armes sont avant
tout fait pour tuer